LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it would be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them,
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it.
And today we're going
to do exactly that.
Welcome to this episode of
"Coffee with a Googler."
I'm Laurence Moroney, and today
we have a really special show.
And if you only ever watch one
episode, let it be this one,
because today we have a cloud
developer advocate called
Heidi Dohse who's joining us.
And Heidi is a whole lot
more than just a cloud
developer advocate.
She's a really inspirational
woman with a great background
and a fabulous story.
But before we get
to that, tell us
all about being a cloud
developer advocate.
What do you do?
HEIDI DOHSE: So I'm on our
Google Cloud Platform team,
and I work with our cloud
product managers, our sales
team, and our engineering
team to kind of figure out
what are we doing with
cloud, customer needs,
and really how do we also
connect the dots internal
to Google to leverage what we're
doing with the Google Cloud
Platform.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Do you have a particular
favorite technology in cloud?
I'm an App Engine guy.
HEIDI DOHSE: So what I'm really
intrigued with what we're doing
is what we're doing with
our Genomics platforms.
Obviously, I have
a passion for, how
do we change the delivery and
the future of health care,
so Google Cloud
Platform is allowing
us to do some really
interesting things
and talk with our
Google Life Sciences
team, who is doing
some great research
and interesting projects.
And all of that
living on Google Cloud
Platform along with
Genomics and then
just creating an
infrastructure that
will allow other companies
to build their medical tools
and products on our service.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now
you've mentioned Genomics
and medical tools
and products, and I
know you've got this
great background.
You used to be like a
competitive windsurfer,
and then life happened.
So tell us about it.
HEIDI DOHSE: Well, I did.
I grew up in the
sports industry.
I was a competitive
windsurfer, skier,
I played multiple sports,
a variety of sports
as a child growing up.
And then one day,
turns out I actually
was diagnosed with a really
rare heart arrhythmia,
and kind of had
my engine tweaked.
And next thing you
know, technology
became very important both on
the inside and the outside.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Nice, and then one day
you learned something
about your heart.
HEIDI DOHSE: I did.
I had one of those moments in
life that changes everything.
I was 18 years old,
and I was going in
between seasons, between ski
season and windsurfing season,
in order to have some
surgery on my knee
to clean up a little bit
of mess I'd made in there.
And I also had my first EKG as
part of the pre-surgery pre-op.
So they put all the
little stickers on me,
and the nurse is
there, and the strip
starts coming out
of the machine,
and her eyes get
bigger and bigger.
And next thing you know,
the cardiologist is there,
and it turns out that 270
beats per minute is not normal.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
HEIDI DOHSE: Yeah,
and so I thought, ah,
that's why I couldn't
count my pulls.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's just so fast.
HEIDI DOHSE: It was.
And my heart rate, it turns
out, would go up as high as 270,
but it would also go down
at like 12 and 14 beats
per minute.
So it was just really irregular.
So there I am-- healthy,
active, 18-year-old athlete--
and they said no knee surgery.
We're sending you off to
the coronary care unit,
and you're now going to
start this journey of a heart
patient.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, wow.
So that led you to like
lots of pacemakers, right?
HEIDI DOHSE: It did.
First, it led me to the-- I
spent a month in the hospital
while they tried to figure
out what to do with me.
They tried all kinds
of experimental drugs.
They tried to figure out
what it was that I had,
and I ended up in
the medical journals,
because it was like, well,
we found something new.
And they said,
gee, we're not sure
why you lasted as
long as you did,
and we don't know how
long you'll be around.
And there's not much
more we can do for you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
At 18, that's got to be hard.
HEIDI DOHSE: It was, and so
I moved to Maui to windsurf,
because I figured
business school was not
going to be as
necessary if I wasn't
going to be around very long.
And then the
following year, I was
invited to participate in
an experimental surgery,
and they electrocuted
my AV node,
which is the part
of your heart that
coordinates the atrium
and the ventricle
and makes it go duh-duh.
And I became 100%
pacemaker-dependent,
and that was 30-plus years ago.
So I have been on the cutting
edge of pacemaker technology
for about 30 years, and
I'm on my seventh one.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
On your seventh one.
HEIDI DOHSE: On my seventh one.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
And now it's like you're
not just sitting around
with this pacemaker.
You're doing pretty extreme and
intense sports with it, right?
HEIDI DOHSE: I am.
It's interesting, because
you have a choice.
You can either be a
victim of your condition,
or you can figure out how
to do really cool stuff,
even though you've
got to deal with it.
So I was a
professional windsurfer
when I had the first one put
in, and I never considered
myself a heart patient.
I just figured I was a girl
with a bad electrical system,
and we fixed it, so I kept
doing what I was doing.
But those first heartbeats
were really clunky,
and kind of this big cigarette
pack of a battery in my chest.
Over the years, the heartbeats
have gotten smoother.
There's more sensors
built into the pacemaker.
So every time I get a new
one, I get new technology.
Just like everything else we
do, the technology gets better,
and when people ask,
oh, gosh, don't you
wish you could just get
it and have it stay in?
It's like, no.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You
want the upgrades.
HEIDI DOHSE: I
LAURENCE MORONEY: For
me, I just think about
getting a new phone for
the upgrades, but wow.
A new pacemaker.
HEIDI DOHSE: No, I
get new heartbeats.
And then the heartbeats
do more, and in 2010, due
to unintended consequences
of lots of surgeries,
I had to have open
heart surgery.
And I decided to be a
competitive cyclist.
And that's when this journey
of extreme endurance sports
started.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
not the usual thing
people go is like, I
had open heart surgery,
so I'm deciding to become
a competitive cyclist.
Where did you make
that connection?
HEIDI DOHSE: You know, because
I had grown up playing sports,
I didn't want to lose being me.
And I just, I think I
was too stubborn to let
heart issues take the life
that I really liked away.
So I just thought,
what the heck?
Let's see how much I can do.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
just pretty amazing.
Now one of the things
is to be able to cycle
and to enhance your ability to
cycle you're using technology.
There's a lot of sensors
in the pacemaker,
and you're using that
to manage your health.
Can you tell us a little bit
about how all of that works?
HEIDI DOHSE: Sure.
So there's a couple of things.
There is what happens inside
my chest with the pacemaker,
and that is the pacemaker
has a gyroscope.
It has oxygen utilization,
muscle stimulation,
electrical impulses.
It takes all of this information
and quickly determines,
hey, this is either
a tachycardia,
or oh, it's actually exercise.
And it does a bit
of machine learning.
So that first 30
minutes of something,
it's kind of taking all this
information in and saying,
OK, great, go do
what you need to do.
And so if I'm doing
a mountain bike race,
and I've got a two-hour
climb in front of me,
my pacemaker will
know what's going on.
So that's what's
happening inside.
But it can still be really
scary just mentally for me,
like how hard can I push
before I explode something?
Which I'd prefer not
to explode something.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, I can see that.
HEIDI DOHSE: So now we have
all these really great wearable
technologies.
We've got between my-- exactly.
So performance athletes,
we've had access
to chest straps and
the polar devices,
or Garmin has some things, but
because of my heart failure
medication and my pacemaker,
the chest straps don't work.
So it took a long
time until we finally
got to where they have
these optical light sensors.
So Mio, Global, couple
different companies
make a really great
wrist-based heart
rate monitor that I use
that I can then determine
when I'm cycling, am I safe?
Am I in that realm
that I need to be?
And then also,
can I push harder?
What more should I be doing?
And that's how it's
really important
to give me the confidence
as a heart patient
to feel safe that I can keep
doing what I need to do,
and then as an athlete, am
I getting the performance
that I should be getting?
Can I train harder?
How much harder can I train?
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
now not just athletes
can benefit from this
technology, right?
So just the average, everyday
person can have a sensor.
HEIDI DOHSE: Exactly.
And I found being a heart
patient for as many years
as I've been and having to
deal with the initial surgery,
new pacemakers being
implanted, open heart surgery,
heart failure, there's a
lot of really scary moments.
There's these times
where it's like, gosh,
is my heart doing what
it's supposed to be doing?
Should I just stay safe,
get in the fetal position,
and lay on the couch,
because you don't
know what's going on inside.
And with these devices and
these sensors and things,
I now have that window
inside of what's happening,
so that makes me feel safer.
And with that safety,
I'm more confident,
and I'm less apt to have that
anxiety that starts to spin,
and then there's anxiety,
and the fear turns
into panic attacks,
and for anyone
that's ever had a
panic attack, you truly
feel like you're dying.
And that can oftentimes,
for an individual,
and I've done it
myself, that ends up
being a trip to the cardiologist
or the emergency room.
There you are consuming these
really expensive health care
dollars, because
you're just sure
you're having a heart
issue, when really you're
kind of having a scary issue.
And the sensors allow you
to catch that and stop
that before it
turns into an issue.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
And they also, would they
allow the doctor to preempt,
instead of maybe
you visiting monthly
or every three
months or something
like that, that they can take
a look at your data constantly,
and then they go, ah, I need to
see her now instead of waiting.
HEIDI DOHSE: Exactly.
So two things there is
that I can eliminate
having to go in for pacer checks
as often, because my Boston
Scientific device has
something called the Latitude
Communicator, and it's
a passive interrogator
that I can just have in my home.
It's collecting data
from my pacemaker
and sending it to my
physician, and they can kind of
look at that.
Everything's
working as intended.
Big thumbs up.
If not, if there's
actually an issue,
they can proactively
call me and say, hey,
let's just check that out.
The other thing is that no one
ever found my heart issue until
I went in for something else,
because it never happens when
you're at the doctor's.
Now people have the ability
to collect more information
on their health, and if they do
see something that's going on,
they can go to their
physician, and they can say,
see this event?
This is what happened.
Here's the actual data,
and here's how I felt. Now
it becomes something
that's actionable.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
And you find things
much quicker, et cetera.
Wow.
And I just still find it
amazing though that despite all
of this, despite this
background that you've
had that these cycle races that
you do, they're tough races.
I saw the one in Vancouver.
You effectively climbed
the height of Mount Everest
over the period of a few days.
HEIDI DOHSE: Yeah.
So I just finished--
it's called BC Bike Race,
and it's a seven-day
mountain bike stage race,
and it's through some of
the most technical mountain
biking in the North
Vancouver, Whistler, Squamish
area, kind of the birth
of mountain biking.
And we did seven
back-to-back days,
over 32,000 feet of climbing--
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
the Mount Everest.
HEIDI DOHSE: Yeah, exactly.
And then this last
weekend I just
did Leadville Stage
Race, where we were doing
climbs up to over 12,500
feet in elevation.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And technology
has made all of this possible.
Obviously, you've put
your hard work in as well,
but the technology's been
one of the enablers for you.
HEIDI DOHSE: It is.
Without technology, I couldn't
be doing what I'm doing.
Without the improvement
in technology
that the pacemaker company does,
I wouldn't have the heartbeats,
and without the technology that
things like our mobile devices,
the sensors allow me as a
heart patient to be safe,
and as an athlete to
have more performance.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Now you're a developer
advocate on the cloud platform.
HEIDI DOHSE: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: How are you
bringing your cloud skills
to this?
HEIDI DOHSE: So all
this data is great,
but how do you actually
get it to the right people?
Well, it has to
live in the cloud.
So I look at what we're doing
with the Google Cloud Platform
as enabling technology
that will really
allow the future
of digital health
and customize personal
health to happen,
because our Google
Cloud Platform
is where the data can be
ingested from the devices,
from the doctor's
office, from the devices.
It can be analyzed, and then
it can be made actionable,
and those actionable bits
can be delivered to a health
care professional, researchers,
individual patients,
and whoever needs to use it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we're
really only getting started.
HEIDI DOHSE: We're
just getting started.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
it's-- thank you so much.
It's such an
inspirational story.
I mean, I find myself like hard
to ride my bicycle at times,
and I'm on my zeroth pacemaker.
And so just thanks for the
inspiration, and best of luck.
I know you've got some
great races coming up soon,
so hopefully we'll get
to see a little bit more
of what you do in
them, and we'll
get to see a little bit
more of how you continue
to use technology to
push the edge of how it
can make your life
better as well
as other people's life better.
HEIDI DOHSE: Wonderful.
Well, thank you so much.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
thanks, everybody.
I hope you really enjoyed
this show as much as I did.
Heidi's just such an
inspiration to me,
and it's making me
get up off the couch
and ride my bike this weekend.
Thanks, Heidi.
And if you have any
questions for me,
or if you have any
questions for Heidi,
please just leave them
in the comments below.
And if you want to watch any
more of the great content
that we have for
Google Developers,
take a look at the Google
Developers Channel.